Boris Johnson wins big for brexit just
hours after the medias say he's down
Nancy Pelosi says the case for
impeachment remains very strong after
dropping the only impeachment offence
charge she had on President Trump and
former FBI director James Comey insists
that the Inspector General vindicated
him on partisan impropriety just days
after the IG explicitly did not
vindicate him all of which shows us a
central feature about the left leftists
we'll never give up the lie they will
never give up the narrative no matter
how clearly the facts contradict them we
will dispel the gas lighting man the
u.s. takes the prize for the highest
rate of single parenthood in the world
congratulations everybody we examine why
and how this all plays into recent
debates about the role of politics in
shaping our culture and finally a
Christmastime miracle all that and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the media got a major conservative
victory wrong again and that's so we're
done that's unfamiliar I don't know we
will get to what happened over in the UK
and what it means for the u.s. first I
got to thank our friends over at
NetSuite one major problem that I have
always seen about growing businesses
small businesses small businesses
becoming big businesses is they have
trouble with their money they have
trouble keeping track of their time and
they have trouble because they can't
keep track of their numbers though their
business systems are a complete
hodgepodge
that is where NetSuite comes in very
handy introducing NetSuite by Oracle the
business management software that
handles every aspect of your business in
an easy-to-use cloud platform giving you
the visibility and control you need to
grow with NetSuite you save time money
unneeded headaches by managing sales
finance accounting orders HR instantly
all instantly straight from your desktop
or your phone time is money
I get it people come in they say all
right I know how to use this software I
know how to use this we'll just use them
and fix it later you're gonna waste a
lot of time NetSuite is the number one
cloud business system in the world it
takes all the fear all the trouble out
of keeping track of your numbers right
now NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm slash Knowles that's
NetSuite comm slash Knowles kano wles to
download your free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits NetSuite
comm slash Knowles
alright last week you've probably heard
you've probably looked at the news
reports that were coming at a major
election in the United Kingdom the key
issue for this election was brexit why
was brexit the key issue three years
after the brexit vote because the media
and the left won't let you move past the
brexit vote because the left assumed
that the brexit vote was going to end in
remain it was going to end in the voters
saying that the UK should stay in the EU
that's not what happened the left has
spent the past three years trying to
undo that vote with this vote and that
vote and you've got some conservative
Prime
Minister but you can't actually get the
vote through because they don't have a
clear enough majority so Boris Johnson
the conservative Prime Minister comes
out and he says we're gonna have a vote
we're gonna put it to the people again
because the left won't let us just pull
out of the EU which shows you the danger
of all these international institutions
we're gonna put it up to a vote again
here's what the mainstream media said
about that election this is just before
the election five days ago
Business Insider the UK could be heading
for another hung parliament as Boris
Johnson's poll lead is cut in half CNBC
pound shaken shaken as a UK election
poll puts Johnson out right when in
doubt reuters knife-edge UK's Johnson
ahead but polls suggest a majority might
be tough right so what they're saying is
okay maybe Johnson is gonna win more
seats than everybody else maybe the
Conservatives will have the plurality of
seats but they won't have an outright
majority and therefore they can't do
what they want to do and therefore
Breck's it's in trouble one report said
that Boris Johnson was hiding in a
fridge literally in a fridge because he
was so afraid of talking to reporters
about this election that wasn't gonna go
his way those are the media set what
actually happened Johnson won more
clearly than any British politician in
18 years Johnson got a bigger victory
than any conservative British politician
since Margaret Thatcher since the 80s it
was a blow out it was an incredible
conservative win the election was all
about brexit which the media say is
unpopular but it's actually popular and
the Conservatives totally want it does
that remind you of anybody that's
unfamiliar to you I don't know about you
all I don't know about how old or young
you are but I am old enough to remember
the election of 2016 when the mainstream
media told us that there was a 99%
chance that Hillary Clinton was going to
win you conservatives shouldn't even
show up to the polls tomorrow it's so
clear and then I I'm old enough to
remember the past three years and they
say Trump is on the ropes the people
want him out he's going to get impeached
he's gonna get removed from office and
then none of that happened none of that
happened
this reminds us of a central fact about
the left it's al its effect I keep going
back to I'm a New Yorker so there's a
lot of idioms a lot of idiomatic
expressions that New Yorkers have heard
one of which is deny till you die
you hear this especially in the
italian-american community deny till you
die
if you go out there and you tell a lie
to somebody never give it up no matter
how obviously the evidence contradicts
you and I've always thought this was
kind of a ridiculous strategy because
you know eventually reality is gonna be
so clear that you can't get away with it
the left never never figured that out
the left is gonna deny till they die
they're gonna keep up the lie they're
never going to give up the narrative I
think what we saw in the UK easily could
be a preview of 2020 in the United
States not necessarily so I'm not
resting on my laurels I'm not saying
Trump is definitely gonna win but it's
the same phenomenon we saw in 2016
oh we saw it now over in the UK there's
something happening around the world
certainly around the Anglosphere but
what look at the polls in America
there's a poll just came out out of USA
Today Suffolk University which is that
after the impeachment hearings the polls
have moved in the direction of
supporting Trump now the majority of
Americans oppose impeachment and removal
from office that was not true before the
impeachment the impeachment has hurt the
Democrats case it's helped Trump 51 to
45 percent so it's not it's not a
blowout but this is even according to
the pollsters 51% oppose removal from
office forty five percent support
removal from office so now as a result
of these numbers Democrats are trying
desperately to prove that this whole
impeachment force has not been a failure
one of the major voices behind
impeachment was Adam Schiff on the house
intelligent committee he goes out and is
speaking to former Clinton hack George
Stephanopoulos and he he comes out and
says this was not a failure gosh guys we
got exactly what we wanted apparently
right now you haven't persuaded a
majority of Republicans that it's worthy
of impeachment and back in March you
also
warned against that you said the only
thing worse than putting the country
through the trauma of impeachment is
putting the country through the trauma
of a failed impeachment if President
Trump is overwhelmingly acquitted in the
Senate is that a failure no it isn't a
failure at least it's not a failure in
the sense of our constitutional duty in
the house and I'll tell you what changed
my mind George because you're right I
resisted going down this road towards
impeachment oh I resisted going down
this road Road toward impeachment except
that I've been leading the charge
literally nothing Adam Schiff just said
is true he has been leading the charge
for impeachment and of course this is a
failure of course it is how else do you
try to spin it they thought they had him
they thought I mean I guess there was
never a chance they were gonna remove
him from office but they dropped their
major charge against him the major
charge that were going after the whole
allegation about the phone call with
Ukraine is that Trump committed a quid
pro quo Trump engaged in bribery Trump
engaged in extortion it was always a
ridiculous charge but at least bribery
is an impeachable offense they had the
impeachment inquiry they had the
impeachment hearings they dropped the
charge so not only is it a failure
because they won't remove him from
office it's a failure because they
couldn't even charge him with what they
were trying to charge him in the first
place
Nancy Pelosi same thing completely
straight face they say has this been a
big flop is this you don't even get him
on the bribery charge
she said we have very strong charges
against the president the president is
wrong look I say we had put forth our
articles of impeachment I'm very proud
of all the committee six committees have
been worth
yes for very long time this is nothing
Swift about it but it is urgent and so
we will be bringing the articles the
committee will work on it today as you
know this I don't know if it's this
morning or this afternoon that depends
on the pace in the committee and then
next week we'll take up side not to be
bribed one of the other I myself I'm not
a lawyer sometimes I act like one not as
it often is I act as a doctor I practice
medicine on the side without benefit of
diploma or two this is a decision that
was recommended by our working together
with our committee chairs our attorneys
and the rest so the articles are what
they are they're very powerful they're
very strong they're very powerful
they're very strong who you're trying to
convince Nancy I love it when the little
bit of humor breaks through there they
say hold on a second nancy pelosi you
said that you were gonna get them on
bribery you said you were a time on quid
pro quo you don't have that what
happened to that legal case she said
well look I'm not a lawyer I mean I
might act like one but not as much as I
act like a doctor with prescription
drugs without a degree not look I don't
pretend to be a doctor as much as I do
drugs and by the way if you're wondering
why I'm acting so odd it might be
because of all the drugs that I just
admitted to doing but she look if I were
Nancy Pelosi I'd probably do a few drugs
these days as well the case falls apart
and yet they're not letting up this goes
all the way to probably the most slimy
crooked guy in the entire process James
Comey we'll get to that in a second
first I've got to thank our friends over
at first leaf and I got to tell you I
know Christmas is coming up fast we're
now in the last-minute gift buying stage
of things you got to get first leaf you
got to get first leave for your friends
and family but more importantly you got
to get it for yourself first leaf is the
coolest wine company I've ever worked
with here's how you get started you get
started on first leaf by taking a quiz
to assess your exact wine drinking
preferences from the sweetness you like
to the different
some wine varietals to everything you
think you know then first leaf creates
an introductory 6-pack of wine for 2995
for no that is nothing for six bottles
of wine that's like one pretty nice
bottle of wine or two you know ok
bottles of wine you get six
these are very nice wines they typically
sell for about $20 a piece so the
bottles arrive and you taste them and
maybe it's not everything you insisted
is your favorite kind maybe they'll
throw one in there you don't know about
maybe though right so you you try them
then you go online and you rate them and
then first beef takes your ratings and
starts to select unique wines for you
based on your tastes for your next
shipment I am so blown away by this
thing I was always skeptical of wine
clubs I love this obviously they gave me
a freebie so I could try it
I'm remaining a subscriber I'm shelling
out my own money for it I love first
leaf every first leave rather sends out
17,000 unique shipments of wine every
single month
the wines are fabulous everyone's tastes
are different first leaf will match you
where you want to be join it today it's
just so great sign up with my link you
will get an exclusive intro offer six
bottles of wine for only twenty nine
ninety five plus free shipping go to try
first leaf dot-com slash Knowles that is
six bottles of wine for only twenty nine
ninety five and I love it I cannot
recommend this thing highly enough
twenty nine ninety five plus free
shipping at try first leaf comm slash
Knowles Cana wles
you heard it from Nancy Pelosi they're
not going to give up the lie the lies
are not going to end okay I think we all
want this moment of catharsis we're
after the Russia hoax and the Ukraine
hoax and the stormy Daniels and then
this and then they're trying to oust
Trump for all these ridiculous reasons
overturn the election we just want this
moment of the left saying you got us you
got us you found the texts between
struck and page okay you've read that
you got the IG report we were wrong
about Russia you read the Muller report
we were wrong about Ukraine we drop the
bribery charge you got us you got us we
were trying to overturn the election
sorry my bad let's try again next time
you want that mole
of catharsis you want that moment of
honesty you're not gonna get it you were
never going to get that from the left
like the most hardened mobster the left
will deny till they die they will never
ever give it up just look at James Comey
James Comey former FBI director and
really the man at the center of so much
of this controversy since 2016 since
2015 James Comey goes on Fox News Sunday
with Chris Wallace and he just does not
give it up Wallace to his credit pushes
James Comey says you know isn't there
something wrong here isn't didn't
something shady go down he won't give it
up he gives a completely straight face
and defends himself former FBI director
James Comey director welcome to Fox News
Sunday thanks for having me
you have been taking something of a
victory lap since the IG report was
released earlier this week the question
is whether or not it's justified here
are you and the Inspector General
Michael Horowitz answering the same
question do you think this is
vindication it is I mean the FBI's had
to wait two years while the president
and his followers lied about the
institution finally the truth gets told
does your report vindicate mr. Comey it
doesn't indicate anyone at the FBI who
touched this including the leadership
the IG says you should feel no
vindication well maybe it turns upon how
we understand the word maybe it depends
on what the meaning of the word is is
you know like is this vindication for me
if is means to be the no no I guess it's
not listen to that Clintonian oily
serpentine it's a clear contradiction
here Comey goes out he says I've been
totally vindicated by the IG the IG
comes out and says Comey has not been
vindicated and you just want James Comey
sitting there in front of Chris Wallace
to say yeah okay you got me yeah fine
you got me but he doesn't do it he won't
give it us as well it depends on what
that word means no it doesn't if the
word has a meaning all right and you're
you're using that word to mean the
opposite of what it means which means
you are
I ain't he goes on he goes on because he
knows he can't totally get away with
this so he has to pretend that he is
apologizing he has to pretend that he's
admitting is wrong but listen carefully
he never does anything even close
seventeen significant errors in the fisa
process and you say that it was handled
in a thoughtful and appropriate way he's
right I was wrong I was overconfident in
the procedures that the FBI and justice
had built over 20 years I thought they
were a bust enough it's incredibly hard
to get a FISA I was overconfident in
those because he's right there was real
sloppy 217 things the user should have
been in the applications or at least
discussed and characterized differently
it was not acceptable and so he's right
I was wrong you know he was right he was
right I was wrong I was just too
confident in all of the processes that
existed and I as a completely passive
figure here I had confidence in it and I
shouldn't have had that confidence the
issue at hand is not James commis
confidence it's what he did it's not
what you thought about things that were
happening outside of you it's what you
did James Comey and and what the IG is
saying is you are not vindicated in what
you did in your actions you acted
inappropriately what you did was wrong
he says I know I don't know that I did
anything it's that I I just had too much
trust and then James Comey goes out
there and he I can't believe he says
this with a straight face
he gives the classic archetype old
epitome of a non-apology apology non
apology
we'll get to that in a second first I
got to thank our friends over at core
shield cars today or like computers on
wheels super computers on wheels
they have electronically controlled
transmissions touchscreen displays a
zillion different sensors and as I
learned unfortunately about three months
ago this technology is very expensive to
fix if and when it breaks and it breaks
it breaks quickly car shield has
affordable protection plans that can
save you thousands of dollars for a
covered repair including computers GPS
electronics and more than that you get
to choose your
favorite mechanic or dealership to do
the work car shield takes care of the
rest
car shield coverage gets you back on
track in no time they offer
complimentary 24/7 roadside assistance
and a rental car while yours is being
fixed car shield has helped over 1
million customers all right million
people can't be wrong
derive with confidence knowing that you
have coverage from America's number one
auto protection provider whether you
have five thousand miles on your car
whether you have 150 thousand miles on
your car it is inevitable that something
is going to break all right this this
happened to me I got caught a few months
ago without this kind of coverage it
cost me big time
all right now I am so thrilled but I of
course shield protection do not wait do
not make my mistake and wait until your
check engine light comes on get covered
by car shield today call 800 car 6000 or
at will and by the way when you call in
mention my code Noll scanner wles or you
can go visit car shield calm and use the
code Knowles canna wles you will save
10% Merry Christmas
that is car shield comm code Knowles
canna wles a deductible may apply ok
James Comey is completely straight face
and then he he makes the most egregious
statement of the entire interview Chris
Wallace says all right you say you were
wrong but then you didn't really take
responsibility for that please
acknowledge the mistakes you made please
acknowledge the inappropriate behavior
you engaged in James Comey responds well
you know gosh Chris you make a great
point I guess I'm just too accountable a
bystander and I witness you were the
director of the FBI well a lot of this
was going on sir
sure I'm responsible for that's why I'm
telling you I was wrong I was
overconfident as director in our
procedures and it's important that it
that a leader be accountable and
transparent if I were still director I'd
be saying exactly the same thing that
Chris Rea is saying which is we are
going to get to the bottom of this
because the most important question is
is it systemic are there problems in
other cases it's not the most important
question the most important question is
what did you do what was your role in
all of this James Comey Chris Wallace to
his credit pushes back on James Comey
says you're pretending
you're some passive observer here you're
not you're the guy who's being accused
of doing this stuff and it looks like
you did it and he says I know I admit
Chris you're right I admit that I was
overconfident no James we're not talking
about your confidence we don't care
about your confidence we care about your
actions in the fisa abuse process and
how do you explain that James Comey he
says look it's very important for people
to be accountable I'm that's why I'm so
accountable then I'm admitting that I
was confident a complete non-answer
Chris Wallace cries what just one more
time just one effort please go me break
that facade and that lie just for one
second he says the IG is contradicting
what you're saying very clearly and
Comey just pretends that he can't hear
the words coming out of Chris Wallace's
mouth it wasn't part of a broader mosaic
that's what you said sir I'm not sure he
and I are saying different things what
his report says is that the FBI thought
it was a close call until they got the
Steele report put that additional
information in and that tipped it over
to be probable cause it's that long FISA
application includes steel material and
lots of other material I don't think
we're saying different things well I
think you are sir because he's saying
you're saying it's part of a broader
mosaic it's just one element he's saying
it was the tipping point
it's what brought it over that doesn't
make it part of a broader mosaic it
makes it the centerpiece of the whole
FISA application and the ability to
surveil Carter page yeah I don't
understand it to be saying that I could
be wrong about that
I got his quote here he says we
concluded the steel reporting played a
seneschal a central and essential role
in the decision to seek a FISA warrant
that it pushed the the FISA proposal
over the line in terms of establishing
probable cause I mean that's what he
says words mean something yeah and I
agree with his characterization I'm just
confused I know I don't see the
disconnect between the two of us that
I'm sorry that I'm missing it yeah I
just don't see it I don't see the
disconnect between my lies and the
reality that directly and explicitly
contradicts
my lies I guess I'm not seeing it Chris
what James Comey is really saying here
is Chris you're trying to get me to
admit that I lied that I acted
inappropriately but I'm James Comey I'm
the former director of the FBI
I'm a left-wing tool and I am never
gonna break I'm never gonna crack this
facade the actual question at hand is
over the spying on the Trump campaign
all right the IG says that the center of
the FBI's case to spy in the Trump
campaign was the steal dossier which was
a farce completely discredited and paid
for by the Democrats Hillary Clinton the
DNC James Comey is saying oh the FISA
the the the steal dossier was just one
aspect of the FISA case so even if you
lose the steal dossier doesn't matter we
still had a strong case to spy in the
Trump campaign that those are two
statements that cannot simultaneously be
true and Chris Wallace is there reading
the words of the IG James Comey is not
an idiot you would have to be so
profoundly stupid to think that those
two statements are the same thing that
they can simultaneously be true and
James come he's not stupid so chris
wallace reads the words from the IG
Horowitz Comey here is the words and he
says nope I look maybe I that's not what
I understand those words to mean I don't
think words have any meaning beyond what
I will them to mean like humpty-dumpty
and Alice in Wonderland Humpty Dumpty
says in my language words can mean
whatever I want them to mean Alice says
can words really mean all those things
and Humpty Dumpty says that's not the
question the question is which is to be
master that's all and that's what the
left would do they would master our
culture master our politics by totally
changing the meaning of words without
any regard to objective reality that's
what they're gonna do the narrative is
everything to the left
the facts are nothing you see this
everywhere from the national level the
international level over the UK all the
way down to the school bus all the way
down to football games two stories in
the media just
over the weekend which show you this
outrageous level of bias young boy was
viciously attacked and beaten up on a
school bus according to his parents
because he wore a make America great
again hat how much have you heard about
that probably not very much another
story is some cadets at the West Point
Army Navy game made the okay sign made
the this the circle game where you show
the circle and you get punched in the
arm this has created headlines all over
the mainstream media about white
supremacy in the military because they
made the okay sign and the circle game
where you get punched in the arm we'll
get into both of those stories we will
then get into an another total race hoax
we'll get into the us highest single
parenthood rate in the world then we'll
get into a Christmastime miracle first I
got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube have to head over to Daly
wire.com you know what you get we now
have multiple tiers of membership so you
can get me you get the and reclaim
ensure you get the Ben Shapiro show you
get the Matt well show you your desk
questions and the mailbag you get
another Kingdom you get so much and then
when you get to our all-access tier we
do these discussions all the time on the
website they're super fun you get to hop
in on those ask questions and engage
with all of the hosts we have a great
time doing it and always love love
talking to the members and the listeners
so head on over and go do that it's
Christmas time so why not treat one of
your loved ones or treat yourself it's a
little screw G but that's okay why not
why not treat yourself daily wire that
gum we'll be right back with a lot more
I show you how the left doesn't give up
the narrative two stories in the media
and one response from a Democratic
congressman first story out of Florida
five young students were charged with a
crime with assault with battery because
a video went online showing this group
of kids pummeling beating the living
daylights out of a 14 year old kid
according to the boy's mother who has
now spoken out about this to local news
stations and on Twitter the boy's mother
says that he was beaten up because he
wore a mag a hat to school and this
caused him to be just absolutely had the
crap beaten out of him
here's I'm just gonna play a little tiny
bit of this video just so you can hear
it I'm not only gonna play maybe 15 16
seconds just so you get the taste it's
actually hard to watch the whole thing
all right the punching this kid in the
head multiple kids boys and girls just
wailing on this kid the school is
denying it had anything to do with the
make America great again happy mother's
saying that's what it was about the
school saying nothing like that and the
Sheriff's Office is denying to pursue it
as a hate crime now why would it even be
a hate crime because beyond the
political aspect to this story there's a
racial aspect the kid who is getting
beaten up is white all the kids who are
beating him up are black does that mean
that this is a racially motivated crime
I have no evidence of that I've no
evidence that it's not that but I
certainly have no evidence that it is
that however if the tables returned if
this were reversed here certainly any
Sheriff's Office would pursue this as a
hate crime for a group of white students
attacking a black student especially if
there were some political aspect that
were were part of the story here let's
say the kid wore an Obama shirt okay or
that would certainly be pursued they
would at least investigate it as a hate
crime
they're not doing that here okay that's
fine I don't think we should have a
primarily racial politics at all I think
it's a bad idea even though the left
tries to push that all the time compare
that story to another story out just
this weekend at the army/navy game on
Saturday a game that I have been to many
times some cadets when the cameras were
going by played the circle game you know
the circle game your index finger and
your thumb together make a circle you
got your other three fingers out and you
put the circle down there and if you
look at it if you make someone look at
the circle you get to punch them in the
arm this is something we all play it in
elementary school at middle school maybe
even high school and the the way you
make the sign is by making the okay sign
which is a very normal gesture that
people make there's an emoji for it and
it's something that the left has now
determined and decided is a white
supremacist hand gesture now how did
that begin it began because of trolls on
4chan who decided to troll the left and
pretend that the okay sign means white
power because I don't need I don't even
really get others works but they're
trying to pretend that in your hand
would spell @w and a P and the they did
this also with a glass of milk
though the people on 4chan said you know
a glass of milk is a white supremacist
symbol because milk is white and so
therefore it means white supremacy and
then the left just runs with this so so
the ADL the anti-defamation league says
this is a white supremacist and symbol I
think the media should laugh this into
oblivion I mean this should not be a
story at all a bunch of cadets making
the circle game psy is obviously not a
news story Wall Street Journal West
Point Annapolis officials investigating
possible white power hand sign New York
Times military investigating suspected
white power hand gestures flashed at
game Washington Post Army Navy officials
investigate white power gestures by
students it's the okay sign at least the
Wall Street Journal to their credit
notes the sign has also been used in
what's known as the circle game where
someone extends the okay sign and if
another person is tricked into looking
at it the second person gets punched in
the arm the sign took on a different
significance for some people around 2017
according to the anti-defamation league
when it began to be used to signify
white power yet took on a different
meaning for hysterical leftists it
didn't take on a different meaning for
racial bigots beyond the racial bigots
on the left the left sees white
supremacy everywhere and when they get
it wrong they just move on there we now
have a case in Florida where these
students racially divided right there's
a racial divide between the perpetrators
and the victim here over a political
question which might have racial
overtones to it as well you get this on
video you get the kids mother saying it
no one will pursue it doesn't matter at
all please tamp it down stop it then you
have some cadets at a football game
playing the ok side they have the circle
game with the okay sign this is an a
national news story about white
supremacy what are the implications for
actual racial violence very little other
than the left will
pursue their narrative they will ignore
fact to contradict their narrative they
will double down on it all the time
where do we see this most particularly
there was a awful shooting last week I'm
sure you saw in the news a mass shooting
in a coach kosher grocery store in the
Greenville section of Jersey City five
people killed including the two
attackers and them the three civilians
who who were being attacked a civilian
and two police officers were wounded and
a Jersey City PD detective was shot and
killed at a nearby cemetery just before
the attack
Rashidah Talib leftist Democrat
congressman tweets that immediately when
this happens this is heartbreaking white
supremacy kills just one problem with
her narrative the attackers were not
white supremacists at least one of them
was a black supremacist a member of a
group called a black Hebrew Israelites
black Hebrew Israelites are a vicious
group if you've ever lived in New York
or DC you've probably come across these
guys I've actually spoken to them at
length because I get a kick out of
people and they stand on street corners
and they scream about the white devil
and all the awful Jews and they're
really vicious racial bigots and yet I
was talking to them for some long time
you know I said why are you talking to
me
he said well you what are you Italian I
said yeah it was wearing Italy that said
my family's from Sicily they say okay
that's all right you're not really white
you're Moorish you're not that could be
a whole other discussion they would not
have spoken to me if they thought I was
white and it's not just white people
that they hate they specifically hate
Jews and now they've actually gone out
and and murdered Jews okay horrific
thing these are the same guys that were
screaming at the Covington kids in
Washington DC with the mag a hat
obviously you didn't hear about that in
the media either because a black
supremacist group killing Jews doesn't
go along with the media narrative what
had receded Talib do when it was obvious
that she was lying did she apologize no
did she refuse no she just deleted the
tweet that's all she just
in the tweet she's not gonna admit she
was wrong that's where we're at okay
stop hoping for the catharsis here in
politics the left isn't gonna give it to
you what you need to do is develop your
own really thick skin here you need to
just look at the facts as you get them
when a report comes out the IG report or
the Mullen report or whatever you got to
read it you are not going to be told the
truth by the mainstream media you have
to read it yourself and when they
Gaslight you which they will do until
the end of time you have to have the
fortitude to withstand it requires a
real level of independent thinking
shifting gears a little bit there's a
new award that the United States has won
this award comes by way of polling from
the Pew Research Center shows that the
United States has a higher share of
single-parent households than any
country in the world
arrey congratulations we did it guys
this survey shows 23% of US children
live with a single adult compared with
an average of just 7% around the world
of these 130 countries rates of
single-parent households ranged from the
low 20s in the United States and in the
United Kingdom
throughout the Anglosphere and and the
West generally to as low as 1 1 or 2%
countries like Turkey or Afghanistan
obviously I wouldn't prefer to live in
Turkey or Afghanistan but it's pretty
pretty big indictment of our culture
that Turkey and Afghanistan are beating
us when it comes to single-parent
households this is important for the
current debate going on on the right
there's this debate we've been having
for a long time between libertarians and
conservatives libertarians on the one
hand are saying that government has no
role whatsoever in fixing our broken
culture the conservatives on the other
hand are saying that politics obviously
affects culture in some ways this is a
good example of how the Conservatives
are right we're not saying politics is
the sure all fixed culture or even the
primary fixed to culture but it does
have some effect libertarians here are
trying to take the Andrew Breitbart
maxim to this completely radical extreme
you know Breitbart said politics is
downstream of
culture that is true but that that
slogan only takes you so far obviously
politics does have some effect on
culture all right here's how you can see
it in just one specific example
even those libertarians would admit that
the New Deal or the the Great Society
programs of the 1960's the vastly
expanded welfare state had a very
harmful effect on the black community
you had all the numbers going in the
right direction among black Americans
murder rates dropout rates welfare out
of wedlock birth abortion right they
were all going in the right direction
they were all getting better and then
you had the Great Society programs of
the 1960's you had these massive
expansions of welfare programs all of a
sudden all the numbers track in the
wrong direction the Great Society
devastated the black community
I'm not even debating the Great Society
programs I'm just saying obviously
politics and government had an effect
there on culture now consider other
political factors when it comes to
single parenthood no-fault divorce no
fault divorce we've had it since the 70s
ironically California was the first
state to pass no-fault divorce laws
under Ronald Reagan said the great
conservative president actually signed
those no-fault divorce laws into law in
the 1970s no-fault divorce means it's a
lot easier to get divorced you don't
have to sue someone and give cause for
divorce to break the contract you just
split you have an a conscious uncoupling
to use Gwyneth Paltrow's line and as a
result of this single-parent households
explode there's another factor single
parent adoption a single single woman
can adopt a kid in the United States in
in most cases those are those are two
political questions as we decided at the
political level they've had an effect on
culture and it would seem to me pretty
clearly not a good effect when you want
to talk about privilege growing up in a
two family two-parent household rather
is an immense privilege to children with
them in particular with their mother and
father that is what you want that's the
best scenario for children our politics
has moved away from that and our cold
is broken his result and we have to go
back and try to change that you know
Rand Paul made a great point about this
the other day on Jake Tapper show not
about single-parent households not about
this broader question of a government
and culture he made the point when it
comes to impeachment he said what we're
seeing impeachment as a symptom of is
this move by the left and maybe even
some aspects of the right to criminalize
politics here he is said you do not
think there will be any Republican
support for removing President Trump in
a Senate trial you will of course be a
juror in that trial so are you still
keeping an open mind about this or have
you already decided you will acquit the
president you know we've seen the
evidence we're gonna hear the evidence
repeated but we're not gonna see any new
evidence so I think all of America has
seen this what we've found is this is a
very partisan exercise there's not gonna
be any Republicans in the house
in fact there'll be a handful of
Democrats who will vote against
impeachment in the house in the Senate I
think all Republicans will vote against
the house and I think two Democrats have
a very good chance of voting against
impeachment also so I think what we've
seen is it's just a very partisan thing
this is a disagreement people on the
Democrat side don't like President Trump
they don't like his demeanor and so they
decided to sort of criminalize politics
but I don't think it's a good thing I
don't think it's a good day for the
country I think it's a sad day because I
hope it doesn't devolve into that every
president like in different parts of
Latin America we either impeach or throw
presidents into jail just because we
don't like their politics mhm I think
that will really dumb down and destroy
the country bingo
right on great point Rand Paul we are
trying to criminalize politics now
obviously in this specific case we're
trying to turn maladministration or
politically incorrect views into an
impeachable events and that shouldn't be
the case the left is the one by far
leading the charge on criminalizing
politics but the sort of hands-off call
it classically liberal or libertarian
right is sort of letting them do it
because they're saying there's really no
legitimate role of government and no
legitimate role of politics in shaping
what happens around us but politics is
just how we live in society with one
another I mean that's a very basic
definition of politics a definition such
that Aristotle would
right the line between culture and
politics is a little bit blurry
it's abortion a political issue or a
cultural issue both is marriage a
political issue or a cultural issue both
obviously what's what's the distinction
you see a hard-and-fast distinction when
you get to government bureaucracy
meetings and writing great novels right
that's a pretty clear politics culture
but on so many of the issues we're
talking about it's a little bit blurry
we should not criminalize politics we
should not back away from politics okay
we shouldn't make it such that if you
have a disagreement with someone you try
to throw them in the clink unless they
committed actual serious crimes likewise
we shouldn't be afraid of engaging in
the political process even if we're on
the right we are going to have to mature
a little bit we're gonna have to learn
we're you know I don't know why people
think that you can just be born into
this world and not learn anything about
your country or your history or your
politics and then go out there and vote
that's very dangerous the a vote in the
hands of someone who doesn't know what
it's worth is a very dangerous thing you
need a populace that is educated in the
traditions of the country in the history
of the country in the mechanisms of
government in philosophy in our own
liberty you need you need people to be
educated in today you need to earn that
if you want self-government to endure
great point from Rand Paul before we go
I want to talk about a Christmastime
miracle because right now we're talking
about how in the realm of politics
hoaxes are being passed off as truths
more broadly especially in the realm of
religion truth is being passed off as a
hoax without any reason
you see this specifically with something
we celebrated on December 12th at Our
Lady of Guadalupe Our Lady of Guadalupe
is a miracle that the Catholics
celebrate but a lot of people don't know
anything about it especially atheists
are agnostic or religiously unaffiliated
or some Protestants or frankly even some
Catholics don't know anything about it
so I just want to bring this to your
attention and maybe expand your mind a
little bit in this Christmas time
miracle the Our Lady of Guadalupe refers
to a miracle
that and if you don't believe in
miracles stick with me for a little bit
I'll present you the evidence it's a
miracle that happened almost 500 years
ago now it started to happen on the
morning of December 9th 15 31 there was
an apparition of Mary Mary the mother of
Jesus and Mary our lady introduces
herself to this kind of peasant or
slightly better off than a peasant
Native American in Latin America outside
of Mexico City named Juan Diego and in
his language in the mattel language the
the apparition and the lady introduces
herself as the mother of a very true
deity and she tells Juan Diego to go to
the bishop and tell the bishop to build
a church on that spot so Juan Diego goes
to the bishop the bishop at that time
was fray Juan de Xoom Moraga he goes to
him and he says this woman appeared to
me says build a church the bishop
doesn't believe him good the bishop
shouldn't just believe some guy who says
I had this vision and I don't have any
evidence of it so do what I say Bishop
acted completely appropriately so Juan
Diego goes back he's going up the hill
sees the lady again the lady says go
back to the bishop time to build the
church Juan Diego goes back again to the
bishop he gets in speaks to the bishop
Bishop says I need some evidence ok I'm
not going to just blindly do what you
tell me to do so Juan Diego then is the
is upset I suppose that he failed to do
what the lady told him to so he's going
on his same Trek but he goes a different
way because he doesn't want to run into
the lady again well as far as
apparitions Marian apparitions go it's
very hard to avoid them if you don't
want to see them for some reason so he
goes around a different way and he sees
the lady again and so what she tells him
to do to give evidence of this is to go
to the top of Tepeyac Hill outside of
Mexico City which is normally barren
this is the dead of winter this is the
middle of December and to gather flowers
Juan Diego goes there and he finds
Castilian roses which are not native to
Mexico and it's the middle of winter
anyway
he finds these flowers and he puts them
in his garment which is called a tilma
right it's this long garment it's like a
working garment so it looks like a
poncho made out of rough plant fiber
they disintegrate within 5 to 10 years
just to work in he puts the roses in
there pulls it up and goes back to the
bishop gets into the bishop and as a
sign shows the flowers the flowers would
be a sign they don't grow in that area
and it's the middle of winter as he's
showing the roses there's an image that
miraculously appears on the tilma and
it's an image of this woman of Our Lady
standing on the moon clothed in the Sun
and everyone is amazed by this and they
have the image and that's the miracle
now now you might be saying okay I don't
believe any of that I don't believe this
happened I don't believe there was the
apparition I don't believe that the
image got there miraculously okay fine
here is where you have to question your
disbelief no one has any idea how that
image got there it's not paint
scientists have examined this very very
closely with super microscopes for
decades now it isn't paint that the
color is just in the fiber somehow
that's the first thing that's a little
weird we don't know what it is the
second thing that's weird is the tilma
is a working garment it should have
dissolved it should have decayed rather
within five to ten years it survived
perfectly intact for 500 years they make
reproductions of it on tilma and those
all decay within 5 to 15 years and yet
this one has lasted perfectly for 500
years if that doesn't do it for you
consider this it survived a bomb blast
in in the 1920s on November 14th 1921
this anti-catholic secularist planted
explosives in a plant right in front of
the tilma the thing explodes the windows
explode the altar that is right below
the tilma completely explodes a crucifix
is all bent over Maasai dove the bomb
blast
and yet the tilma completely untouched
looks exactly like it did the day that
it appeared so not only does it survive
500 years of people handling it and soot
from candles and all sorts of things
that should make it decay it survives a
bomb no explanation for that whatsoever
and then one of the wildest aspects of
this is they looked at this very tiny
image it's really not that big they put
it under a super microscope when they
look into the eye and the way that our
eyes work right as you can see in your
I what I'm seeing you can see it in the
reflection right so if you've zoomed
into my eye right now you would see some
cameras and some lights and things like
that this is the reflection of what
we're seeing right so they zoom in on
this very very tiny microscopic eye in
the image and when they blow it up they
see the reflection of an old man looking
shocked in the image and the people in
the room first of all there's no way
that we we wouldn't have understood how
the human eye works five hundred years
ago in and certainly a Native American
peasant and Mexico wouldn't have
understood that this was not
acknowledged until recent decades
because we just didn't know was there
because we didn't have the technology to
see it and it isn't pain so it's not as
though someone painted it on but even if
they did painted on there's no way that
it could be small enough for them to
possibly paint this there is no
explanation for it this is an important
flipside to what we're talking about
today especially as we move into the
Christmas season so much in politics
that we see that we know to be a hoax is
passed off as truth in this absolute
regime of Lies that we see from the left
from the media so many people telling us
political lies even occasionally people
on the right stretch the truth all right
willing to acknowledge that that's what
we get in politics and yet on these
eternal questions on these metaphysical
questions on these things that are
utterly unexplained other than by
revelation other than by the miraculous
we're told that the truth is a hoax and
the people who tell us the truth is a
hoax never explain how it's a hoax they
never give any evidence for their claim
they never give any explanation for the
unexplained they just want us to believe
that the truth is a lie and that the
lies are the truth and we've got to
resist all of that all right that's our
show come on back tomorrow
I'm Michael Noel's this is the Michael
Nolt show see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key
edited by Danny D'Amico audio is mixed
by Mike or Amina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh show we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
you